ridley scott's sci-fi opus blade runner  has become known as one of the best most  influential movies of all time one of  the movie's best lines however didn't  come from screenwriters rather it came  from the actor playing the role rutger  hauer hower plays roy the leader of a  band of replicants basically  bioengineered androids created for slave  labor to prevent a full-on revolt  scientists give replicants a limited  four-year life span roy spends the movie  trying desperately to find a cure for  the design flaw dooming him and his  friends to short lives by the end of the  film he's given up hope and spares the  blade runner deckard played by harrison  ford hired to kill him during a table  read of the script while reciting his  final monologue rutger hauer added a  final coda all those moments will be  lost in time like  tears  in rain the line was so well received  that it was added to the script and it  has since become one of the most quoted  bits from the entire movie